warum ist einfach vor mit uns passiert
das meer und das warum ist eigentlich
passiert und warum muss jedes jetzt
außerdem der neunjährige q2 war einer
von 17 personen einer syrischen
großfamilie die nach langer flucht in
der schweiz wieder zusammenfanden
geholfen hat ihnen ihr sohn und bruder
basel massa er lebte damals schon fünf
jahre in der schweiz familie meinen
dicken
[Musik]
ich habe ihn gefragt hast du angst dass
die flugzeuge hier kommen meint er ich
habe angst dass sie wie ist es wenn man
die flucht geschafft hat den krieg aber
in sich trägt
davon handelt dieser film bei der
ankunft fünf monate zuvor konnte niemand
von ihnen deutsch
cousins eltern gehören zu den wenigen
die von beginn an einen deutschkurs
besuchen dürfen war in syrien lehrerin
und amar hatte an die mechaniker
werkstatt hier fangen sie wieder ganz
von vorne an
[Gelächter]
ihr neunjähriger sohn cruz konnte in
syrien wegen des krieges nur ein jahr
zur schule gehen
55 kinder
und er spricht alle schon deutsch konnte
etwas helfen
guten morgen
das ist was ich bin
fr mai alle 17 personen der syrischen
großfamilie leben hier in diesem zentrum
sie teilen sich die küche mit 180
anderen und träumen davon schon bald
eine eigene wohnung zu haben
[Applaus]
haben sie eine wohnung anschauen können
nein das kann man vergessen vielleicht
nach einem jahr oder mehr
sie haben uns gesagt im moment ist der
umzug noch ein traum
sind sie enttäuscht
natürlich es ist schwierig hier zu leben
wir müssen das essen im zimmer
vorbereiten dann hierher kommen
manchmal gehe ich vier mal oder häufiger
zurück ins zimmer wenn ich koche einmal
vergesse ich das salz dann die tomaten
das ist schwierig ihre flucht begann
schon lange bevor sie in die schweiz
kamen seit zwei jahren sehnen sie sich
nach ein bisschen privatsphäre ein viel
diskutiertes thema auch bei den männern
aber naja usern auftrag das motto für
nazi hasler kröner visier ich sollte
wieder fein und
nach einem ihrer werke ist die ganz
verschiedene aspekte merke dass mir
einigermaßen spezielle wirtschaftler
funktionieren und muss vorher gar rechts
jahre so gesetzt dass man das alles
funktionieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
rusal besucht inzwischen die
primarschule im dorf zusammen mit
anderen kindern aus dem
durchgangszentrum wand an wand mit
cruise als familie leben seine tante und
sein onkel nach vorn im
durchgangszentrum wie alle erwachsenen
hier verfolgen sie ständig die news zu
syrien
das ist gerade eine reportage von al
jazira
es geht um unsere stadt talbisseh er hat
mir gerade geschrieben dass es wieder
vier luftangriffe gab auf ein spital
er hat informationen über dieses spital
davon ist arzt er kümmerte sich um
verletzte
bis seine praxis völlig zerstört war mit
hilfe ihres verwandten basel in der
schweiz haben sie sich als letzter der
großfamilie auf die flucht gemacht
ihre tochter lilian war knapp ein jahr
alt sie schläft dauernd und wie alt ist
ihr zweites kind
zwei wochen rafa war auf der flucht im
vierten monat schwanger
wie heißt sie nehmen ihr name ist verrat
das heißt glück auf arabisch wir hoffen
dass sie etwas glück haben wird
ihre schwester lehrern wurde in syrien
geboren aber sie lebte nur 15 tage in
ihrem zuhause in syrien
sie weiß bis heute nicht was es bedeutet
ein zuhause zu haben ein eigenes zimmer
eigenes spielsachen
kürzlich fragte sie mich mama wo ist
unser zuhause
wir hoffen es wird besser
wegen der kinder
die ganze großfamilie lebt noch im
durchgangszentrum zwei der familien
haben bereits einen positiven
asylentscheid und dürfen jetzt eine
wohnung suchen nicht so sehr von und
rafa vor ein paar tagen kam er nicht
die post sei also ihr asylgesuch wurde
abgelehnt und zwar wegen folgendes er
wurde nicht geglaubt dass das er ein
jahr lang in sillian gesucht war um
nicht erwischt wurde das bedeutet sie
bekommen keine papiere dürfen nicht
reisen und vor allem nicht arbeiten
allein schon weil hertie an amanda
zusammengefasst was er sagte er brauchte
ins jeden ein jahr bis er seine tochter
registriere registrieren lassen könnte
und jetzt hätte er hier einen pastor
hätte das land verlassen
also wenn er könnte wieder die schweiz
verlassen genau das ist was man ja das
hat er schon erwähnt er war bei einem
anwalt und er hat ihm gesagt du hast
sehr gute chance und sehr wahrscheinlich
in den nächsten tagen wird den anwalt
der lupus weiterleiten
die eltern von kusel hingegen haben eine
bewilligung bekommen
sie dürfen in der schweiz arbeiten und
den wohnort selber wählen
für q cells sind vor allem dass er neue
freunde gefunden hat uns als familie hat
erst nach einem jahr und sieben monaten
als letzte das durchgangszentrum in lyss
verlassen ihre erste wohnung haben sie
in königs gefunden
und wie geht es ihnen
gott sei dank wir sind ja hier in der
schweiz wir sind nicht in syrien jetzt
in diesem moment und will aber wir sind
nicht glücklich
ja man kann sehr schwierige leben ohne
sprache ohne arbeit ohne etwas zu machen
ohne freundin kappus ein arbeit wir
besitzen ganze da und wir haben viel
stress was du was wir sollen machen
jetzt in dieses buch etwas was können
wir machen und wir haben wie viele
chance haben viel vor einen arbeit
finden lassen die eltern verfolgten
permanent online nachrichten aus syrien
das macht mehr traurig vor meinen kinder
weil haben morgen das nicht
die ruhr nachrichten für syrien und so
liegt sachsen waren sie wisse was er tue
das ja das sind sie für das war nicht
gut was macht er aber für sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr viel kostet ja nicht so weit
und sie sehen unglücklich und mitmachen
bei dem man fand ihn lieber nachrichten
logisch und machst du das ist wichtig
wir konnten nicht das lass sein und
vergessen und dann schon erleben
ja ja das macht mehr hat wäre
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was wäre haben gemacht mama meinst du
das leben neu gestalten
die siebenjährige tschudi macht es so
kruse hat die nase voll vom krieg aber
die bilder lassen ihn auch nach über
zwei jahren in der schweiz nicht los
nach sie mir einfach ganz knapp 6
und ja immer mehr blut und zimmer fast
und ja sie dass sie mir einfach in
meinem haus gegangen wäre sehr angst der
mutter liegt und warum passiert das
jetzt
kilian okay und ich sehr beliebt so
mache jetzt mal acht muss sie immer
einfach
und ja und beim anpfiff bis ich ja
manchmal
der zweite sitzt die lytro wird nicht
und wir bluten fachjury sie einfach
margarine besteht allerdings muss im
online kurs ist über gesang stoppen
musste
die aracom jetzt mann ist weder der
mache ist nicht einfach so dass sie so
stark war einfach danke dass terroristen
sie und mir nicht gut so und das wird ja
das sagen dass mir das also wird nicht
sagen dass man sie nicht dass sie aber
ja nicht einfach nicht
die yakuza ist jetzt zwölf jahre alt und
in der fünften klasse alle seine
mitschüler wissen dass er aus dem krieg
kommt benedikt flüchtet und politisch
groß dass sie werden also weniger
mittwoch stimmt das ist gut sagt du hast
fast alles
36 das heißt das hast du auch gegen und
wieder nichts gemacht außer zeigt sind
noch mal und noch ist es auch dort um
eines ganz fertig ist ist es ist
erstaunlich was kussa in diesen zwei
jahren gelernt hat und deutsch spricht
und deutsch versteht auch montag bereits
es ganz ganz verblüffend die mutter
arbeitet als zitrone szenario zeit habe
er das zeitzer sturm aufgabe und
intimität und er trotz guter witz und
lamb wirtschaft sehr gut oder 140
freizeitspielern das auf dem spielplatz
machen enorm wichtig auf eine tätigkeit
die wetten haben außerdem sechs punkt
also haben wir sechs richtige gemacht
setzt und deckelt noch ein noch schnell
ein bunny was wir noch anderen 1
auswählen
doch nicht
beck
ja ja ja ja
[Musik]
irgendwann im schnitt sollen dann kann
das politische berlin hatte das gesagt
oder wieso handel war sie schon nicht
ganz einfach zu flüchten und das ist für
den sabine auftrumpfte streamen und
damit letztlich auch hier schweizern
sitzen
vor genau drei jahren haben sie alle
erstmals schweizer boden betreten es war
so kalt wie heute und die kinder hatten
noch angst vor flugzeugen sie verstanden
nicht und hatten keine ahnung was das
wort heimat bedeutet der rosengarten
entfernt ist so eine art
familientreffpunkt geworben
[Musik]
ich komme auch schon höre mir gerne
ihnen zu singen davon der arzt nicht
herkommen
ihm geht es nicht gut seine familie
wartet seit über zwei jahren auf den
außen entscheid
sie haben verlag keine ausweis auch
gegeben
sie haben uns um im bfm gesagt er will
muss warten bis wir eine entscheidung
haben und man sie gern
[Musik]
alle verkaufen ist nicht alles
verspielen
damals vier davon